kids adopt ice they hold it in their
hand it's real has a purpose to give it
life in their imagination and you can
see how physical computing taps on that
many of our activities we build
something that looks like a toy maybe a
little pet then we use code and we use
maybe the lights that we have on the
microcontroller to give life to that
virtual that real pet so for example if
you wiggle it then your virtual cats
starts to meow
right or it starts to show a happy face
so it is in a sense very real for
children
you're listening to the Microsoft
Research podcast
a show that brings you closer to the
cutting edge of technology research and
the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen using
[Music]
if you've ever wondered if you could
find the perfect combination of computer
scientists and MacGyver look no further
than dr. Polly duello principal research
software design engineer at Microsoft
Research a key member of the MSR rise
for research and software engineering
group Pelle is part of the make code
initiative that brings physical
computing to classrooms around the
country and around the world today Pelle
talks about the maker movement in k-12
education the hard work that goes on
behind the scenes to deliver a seamless
user experience for both kids and
teachers and how to get children excited
about coding through hands-on experience
in early computer science education that
and much more on this episode of the
Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
so you and I share a difficult to
pronounce last name oh yeah how do you
say your name my last name is do i do do
i do i do yeah that nasal sound pretty
hard i've receive every possible
pronunciation back yeah and spelling I
bet listen
several of the researchers we've had on
this podcast have talked about an aha
moment in their own lives or they said
hey that's what I want to do with the
rest of my life did you have one and if
you did what was it well I'm from the
you know the 8-bit computer generations
at Commodore computer and played a lot
of games on it I had to type them so
that my first programming experience was
just writing a loop there I think it was
saying something like poop in the loo
but surprisingly an emoji
I learned WordPerfect and I learned how
to like automate you know like this hole
you could put names in things and print
500 times in the same page and I really
liked the fact that I made stuff though
as programming is really a Word document
I really dig that but I've really got
seriously into coding in college before
I was mostly small-time hacking of games
and yeah so from there to Microsoft
Research what was your path I did a PhD
in applied math and previous life and
then I got in contact with people in
Microsoft and I got a job as a tester in
the.net runtime I was two years a tester
for the just-in-time compiler so that's
the thing that takes dotnet bad code and
turns to assembly and then you know from
meeting other people I got sucked in
into working on a testing tool called
pecs in in Rhys pecs was a white box
test generation tool that uses something
really cool called dynamic symbolic
execution and it is still available for
your studio and then finally my
colleague said oh you know it's hard to
demo this thing let's put a web
front-end to it and my colleague nikolai
tilman is the one who started the
project so we did that and then
collaborator towers she said oh you
should make it a game
people have to figure out the code they
don't have to test it so we did that too
and then surprisingly people liked the
game yeah it played the game a lot
some people like puzzles this is the
ultimate puzzle you have to
reverse-engineer a programming function
that might be very complicated and
that's how I think from one step to the
other we ended up in education so you're
in Ryze research in software engineering
at Microsoft Research
what kind of research do you do
currently I'm working on building code
editors for beginners for kids around
physical computing around teaching
computer science around building things
and programming physical stuff but rised
as a lot of things I'm just one aspect
or the group much of your recent work is
in what you call the maker space the
maker space what do you mean by that
it's kind of a buzzword right now the
maker movement they know that C is a
movement and there's things called Maker
Faire and make magazine you know it's
allowing people to build things you can
build it and kind of celebrating making
things and using any kind of technology
whether it's old things like forgery or
cutting wood or mixing new technologies
mixing 3d printing and arts and painting
I think the maker movement doesn't
really care about how you build things
there is certainly a trend where because
microcontrollers are easier to program
there's more of these kind of technology
that is being accessible to
non-professional developers right and
that's one of the aspect of the maker
movement so how is Microsoft research
involved in that movement the physical
computing kind of taps trade into the
maker movement we enable it we enable it
because we lower the barrier of entry in
terms of programming making things that
leverage microcontrollers and coding so
you don't need to learn an advanced
language like you know C++ you can use
drag-and-drop programming just like
you're doing you know in the hour of
code for example well talk about
physical computing for a minute what do
you know about it what do you do with it
right it's a mouthful of physical
computing what is it we use small
microcontrollers so little computers
think about the size of a watch that you
can program
and we allow the kids to use code to
build things so these little computers
have sensors that can detect maybe
movements or lights or sound and they
have output so they have like lights or
they can do sound or they can't start
activating motors but you bill actually
physical things because it's a real
tangible something can touch so that's
why it's called physical computing okay
so you told me it was important for kids
to interact with a physical object in
addition to or before they code it to
animate it or give it life right so that
that's the masterplan kids enough toys
they hold it in their hand it's real has
a purpose to give it life in their
imagination and you can see how physical
computing taps on that many of our
activities we build something that looks
like a toy I may be a little pet out of
cardboard then we use code and we use
maybe the lights that we have on the
microcontroller to give life to that
virtual that real pet so for example if
we wiggle it then your virtual cats
starts to meow right or it starts to
show a happy face so it is in a sense
very real for children that's awesome
so on your shelves in your lab I saw
electric guitars
I saw light-sensitive robots monsters
even I saw soil sensors these are all
things that happened in a classroom talk
about your experiences that are
happening with physical computing in the
classroom so what we're seeing with
physical computing is that it's easy to
build projects that are meaningful for
students there are real projects the
range of project you can address by
building physical things is very large
because it is reality you know the
example like to mention is medical
devices wherein students want to help
their grandparents who you know detect
but their fall is a classic one that's
the kind of stuff you can build with
microcontrollers the kids who like
sports you can do sports oriented things
the kids are like fashion you can do
lights there's a wide range of interest
that we know kids have that we can
address the other thing that's really
interesting with physical computing is
the infinite level of customization can
apply to them and it
very important for students to own what
they're building to feel that that's
theirs and if you're following too many
instructions you know you have the same
thing as your neighbor on the left and
the right
doesn't feel like you've yeah
if you build a cardboard robot and you
decided it's a dragon and your neighbor
it's a cat and you know when it's a
pizza
you've kind of got your interests you're
in full learning mode yeah and gets to
the when it gets to the coding part so
what I'm hearing is this domain lead
which is a more technical way of saying
making it your own but you find the
interest level of the maker the kid the
developer whatever and then you bring in
the computing and the coding and so on
we make it so that the computing is
friction free it's not a pain to be
brought in and in sense it's seamless
and you want to bring it in if anytime
you're going to add friction to to
something people are gonna say it's no
it's too complicated I won't do it next
time and so forth giving life to these
microcontrollers and these robots has to
be so seamless that any teacher is going
to say I'm gonna take a chance and you
know and do it although I'm not an
expert here so talk about the technology
that goes on behind that so that it
comes into the situation seamlessly so
at the hardware level we have these new
boards that are full of sensors so
that's the hardware part at the software
side we need software that is adapted to
today's you know 21st century classroom
so we have browser-based code editors
these are a completely cross-platform
they will work in diverse environment
schools may have deployments of Windows
machines and maybe some iPads and
Chromebooks and whatever came in the
middle so it's very diverse so we do all
cross-platform we work offline in case
your Wi-Fi is really not good and also
we have developed boot loaders and new
file system to be able to flash a device
via drag-and-drop and that starts to
reflashing process so these boards only
run one program they run the latest
program you've flashed them and this
kind of unlocks the k-12 world that
leads into a really good question about
physical computing for everyone yeah
it's been going on for a while and I'm
Mike
research the first project I know of was
Gadgeteer by Steve Hodges and they had a
you know a module system and they had a
coding experience in c-sharp in Visual
Studio and then we got the opportunity
to work with the BBC to help deliver the
micro bit and we tweaked touchdevelop to
support the micro bit but we also built
an editor based on blockly so the
typical drag-and-drop blocks you would
use when you're using the ARF code or
scratch play they feel the same way so
there's been quite a bit of activities
in ms are around physical computing for
a good while what are you guys doing
here in terms of broad thinking on
inspiring creativity in computer science
wit physical computing and in most of
our resources in mate code we first make
something and we make something because
that thing is going to be in a sense
custom for every kid when we do a
virtual toy or a pet or an instrument
there is a high level of customization
duct tape pencils whatever they have in
your hands and catering it right I mean
kids are really good at crafting they
love that that means they own the device
the device has a life on its own on
their eyes it has a personality and then
it's much more meaningful for them to
start working on programming it so
that's in a sense what you get for free
when you're building physical things is
that there's this whole crafting thing
that people typically love to do back to
the maker back to the maker yes yeah
that does seem like a good approach is
to get kids making things and then
seeing how what the possibilities are
with computer science so in the making
what's interesting is we know we call it
physical computing and similarly coding
is a big aspect of that but what quickly
discovers that in the making kind of
ecosystem there's some kids are really
interested in coding some of them are
really designers they love to design the
hardware they're not so much interested
about the rest but they like to design
the experience but did not really like
to implement it although like that it
looks good like the colors are going to
be very important and you know
it may show them that there is a space
for them as designer and has you know a
graphic artist in the technology stack
where it's not just code monkeys it's
not just developers we need designers we
need you know great graphic artists user
experience designers and things like
that and building real things and you
build them in the team as well you
working as a team is inherent when you
need four hands to do something you're
gonna work as a team right you know that
reminds me that we discussed the wide
range of interests and occupations where
you could find a place in high-tech and
you mentioned sports medicine fashion
games toys Hardware all in the context
of software engineering so talk about
where you could bring in these other
interests and still find a place in
high-tech let's say I want to pique the
interest of some students and I know
they're high into sports then I'll make
a lesson around using an accelerometer
sensor to detect let's say how many
steps they've done or you know how many
G's they took when they took this sack
and football or you know how many times
you can juggle with the ball before the
ball falls for example but you tap into
their passion passion sports if you're a
natural born medic you know you love to
help people and we see that in many
students when we do a test you party
want to build a medical device and a
medical device that we had to go who
tracked the water intake per day because
some people forget to drink so they need
to be reminded to drink a few times a
day but that was directly in our
instance was to build an device that
would help other people some kids love
games so they're gonna be games there's
always those ones and then some students
music you know sounds was great so you
know because technology is going into
every aspect of life today we can use
that to really excite kids about it by
just tapping into your interest
talk a little bit about the beginnings
of touchdevelop
how did that come about as an idea
Nicolai tilman which was also in the
rice group you know he got a phone like
everybody else when the iPhone came out
and after two weeks he rushed into the
manager's office because he had
downloaded all the apps and he was bored
and so he was program this thing and
we're all a generation that learned to
code out in Commodores and computers and
like we need to bring back the joy of
programming of 8-bit computers to phones
and I think everybody turned their head
and say like oh yeah that's a great idea
we should totally be able to do that
since the hardware specs are much better
than what we had back in those days in
our case we touched Eva we were like we
want to be able to code on a phone for
example and the experiment has to be
good even if you're just holding it with
one hand and using one finger so the
better experience was you know writing
texts the way you've been writing texts
on it something that's designed to have
a keyboard we know hundred two keys
right it's not gonna work when you don't
have keys and you just have a
touchscreen so you're not really
leveraging the new specificities of the
you know modern phone hardware that just
actually sounds exciting that it was an
exciting time well so talk about how
touchdevelop played out then after the
idea came it got pitched here in
Microsoft Research and everyone said hey
great idea let's go what happened so we
grew and then we used it to develop new
ideas around distributed computing maybe
interfaces on the code we I know we do
publish these results as we go we were
an early adopter doing the hour of code
with the RF code when it came out dark
we could add org so we explored how far
you could go with a phone only
experience then we expanded to all
computers so they were interesting
questions like programming on multiple
devices at the same time so handling you
know what happens when your program on
these devices are on and off the school
setting how do you handle multiple
screen size and the unified coding
experience around that ultimately
touchdevelop
got us into the physical computing
so we had done some experiment with Lego
NXT and then we started working on the
BBC micro bit talk a little bit about
the micro bit for a second because that
device is packed right the micro bid was
piloted by the BBC they have a research
department too and they went through
four or five prototypes I think so they
prototype hardware ditz
discovered that a screen was very
important and buttons were cool and
things like that so they did the user
research what's the best age to kind of
introduce this kind of tech and things
like that and then when they wanted to
go big because the plan was to give a
micro bit to every student in the UK
every year 7 students so every
eleven-year-old so at that point they
did it a call for partners and then
anybody who wanted to help could join
the party talk to me about make code a
little more that's the big thing that's
happening right now in the school
setting how did that evolve out of other
things that you were doing in research
and what's it doing now make code is a
direct evolution of touchdevelop
then touchable for micro bit we did a
full rewrite and then we started working
with developer division here which is
the same division that does Visual
Studio we got a team of engineers and
started making it a real product we are
all open source on github and we started
working with companies to help them
bring their microcontrollers to to the
market so we're working with the
foundation of course the micro pet
foundation but we also work with it a
fruit and others and so what do you do
with the schools now with mate code so
it's cool today with make code can do
minecraft programming and they can do
the Adafruit circular playground they
can do the chibi Tronics chippy chip
they can also do the C the Grove zero
board and there's a few others in the
pipeline but that's those are the ones
that are are you is your group typically
present or is this like logon and go to
the teachers yeah mostly it's logon and
go we do some user testing where we
don't follow a class for a week
so we have regular user testing around
that otherwise it is used worldwide we
see the tweets coming back from the
teachers when they published their micro
pets you know micro pets is our first
lesson on the micro bit course yeah and
typically teachers are really impressed
by what the kids come up so we see some
pictures popping up on Twitter your
audience has been professional
developers and that you've now moved
into the end users who are not
programmers and beginning programmers
often in school situations it seems like
there's a push to evangelize the
programming world this shift happened
really when we started doing
touchdevelop
so traditionally Microsoft would sell
visual studio and then they have visual
studio code which are pro grade IDs so
even if you understand what ID means
you're a pro so there are professional
code editors and there are foreign
audience of professional developers and
or at least people are serious about
coding when we started doing
touchdevelop we basically ended up being
an app and apps are downloaded by
regular consumers who may have zero
experience around coding so obviously no
children have phones so there would be
our at least teens iPhone we like an
interesting audience to to appeal to and
so that's really how by saying we're
gonna program on the phone we're also
saying or no we're gonna actually
address a new audience an audience that
doesn't has never coded because an
audience that already codes let's say on
a keyboard the typically gonna see that
and said this doesn't make sense they
have a paradigm now if you come to the
ones who have never known anything else
on the phone it's very natural you know
what is this thing with a keyboard
how much hand-holding has to happen in
these new environments where you if
someone downloads an app it's like well
I would say how do I use that yes so we
content is key there's a lot of content
there's a lot of work around intelligent
tutorials and I think we don't know
precisely you know what's the best and
probably there's no students that are
the same so things are going to work
sometimes or not we do also a lot of
work to please the teachers we do work
to provide curriculum that our standards
Ally
that teachers can use to deliver to
class that's very much so that comes out
of your group as well we work with
educators to design material that a
teacher would like to read which is not
what you want to read they have their
own language so we we build material for
teachers so that a teacher can adopt
this and say okay I will reach all the
standards I have to teach and I can do
that and this is exactly what I'm
looking for and we also build material
for the random user that's going to use
the app the random kid so small projects
maybe some guided tutorials where we
tell them precisely how to drag the
blocks here and there
our latest editors have a kind of like a
gallery setting where you go shopping
for if you go to our minecraft editor
for example you'll see we have I think
40 projects that are completely crazy
and they have like shiny screenshots and
then oh I want to do a Batcave okay I'll
learn about the Batcave or I want to do
like super digger so we tease the
interests of the children by doing some
really cool mods typically very small at
least to get started we seed the
environment with a lot of people will
learn just by looking an example then
we're mixing it so we see the
environment with that we also have two
tours that are guided where it's a very
precise route these are usually the
first ones to teach you how to edit or
work like how you drag things and which
button to press when you're ready in
touch Devo we had something super
advanced around that this is still a
very very active area of research that
can grow yeah so there's all kinds of
places to go from here it's a very
interesting space that has massive
potential how can you maximize let's say
people want to learn something online
how do you build a system that really
maximize our learning for all the users
if you want to be successful if you want
to really have a platform that helps
people learn otherwise you know you will
drop your students they will not come
back because they feel like they're
losing their time you're fighting
against all the distractions that are
available on the internet so it's a tall
order to keep your your audience well
that's the world your research is living
in right now is the distraction world
yeah you have to be interesting
otherwise they will just go to the other
tab and
and go back to there you know best
favorite activities of the day well it
seems like what you're doing is really
interesting very true we're very to be
very interesting and have people learn
and you know maybe change some lives
along the way yeah changing lives it's
good to learn more about dr. Pelle
Bella's work with make code and other
innovative things Microsoft Research is
bringing to your kids classroom visit
microsoft.com slash research
[Music]